hass und beschimpfungen im netz ein
massenphänomen
es betrifft sehr häufig frauen darunter
viele politikerinnen
doch was wenn die justiz beleidigungen
als rechtmäßig einstuft dagegen kämpft
renate künast es begann 2015 mit diesen
facebook post ein blogger verfälscht ein
zitat wonach sie angeblich sex mit
kindern befürworte daraufhin entlädt
sich ein schütze mit beschimpfungen weit
unter der gürtellinie künast verlangt
von facebook die daten der nutzer um sie
anzuzeigen klagt gegen die plattform
doch sie unterliegt vor der pressekammer
des landgerichts berlin
sie kam im ergebnis zu der auffassung
dass diese kommentare noch als zulässige
meinungsäußerungen zu bewerten seien
die begründung die äußerungen hätten
einen sachbezug zur pädophilie debatte
der 80er jahre
zu der hatte sich die politikerinnen
damals missverständlich geäußert
künast stellt klar dass die pädophilie
immer abgelehnt habe das zitat gefälscht
sei doch die richter meinen sie habe
damals sex mit kindern verharmlost und
dass sie sich daher sehr weit überzogene
kritik gefallen lassen muss
es gab stellen das schreiben sie das sei
eine satirische überspitzung wo ich
gedacht habe ich glaube ich verstehe
satire nicht mehr
renate künast will dieses urteil nicht
akzeptieren und berufung einlegen die
entscheidungen der nächsten instanz
dürfte signalwirkung haben und über
dieses thema wollen wir uns
ausführlicher sprechen im studio begrüße
ich jetzt den rechtsanwalt für presse
und persönlichkeitsrecht christian
schertz einen schönen guten morgen schön
ist so ganz im zdf sind
verschärft werden den bei den einspieler
gerade zusammen schon gesehen das
berliner landgericht hat in seiner
urteilsbegründung keine diffamierung
renate künast feststellen können
außerdem müsste sie sich als politikerin
überzogene kritik gefallen lassen was
sagen sie dazu wie schätzen sie dieses
urteil ein
man kann das nicht eindeutig genug sagen
dieses urteil ist verheerend für die
streitkultur im netz aber auch überhaupt
in der politischen debatte
es setzt ein zeichen dass dem wutbürger
sogar mut gemacht wird er praktisch
sogar ermutigt wird solche horten
formulierungen im bezug auf politiker zu
wählen
ich kenne die kamera ich kenne das
gericht ich bin auch in zwei stunden bei
denen im gerichtssaal verhandelt eine
andere sache
ich kann ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen was
die kamera wirklich geritten hat eine
solche absurde rechts staatsfeindliche
entscheidungen zu treffen wenn ich
allein mir die begründer und ich bin
immer freund der konkreten quelle
ansehen
da heißt es die äußerungen knatter sie
doch einmal so richtig durch bis sie
wieder normal wird ist sicherlich eine
geschmacklose kritik wie die videospiel
stilmittel der polemik aber sachliche
kritik übt oder die aussage im bezug
ich wusste es zitieren weil man darf ja
so formulieren
der kommentar der exporte bewegt sich zu
haarscharf an der grenze das von der
antragstellerin also fast noch
hinnehmbaren also das ist insofern wäre
neben der sache und auch neben all dem
was ich bisher an gerichtsentscheidungen
kenne und auch selbst betrieben habe
früher waren aussagen wie stein dummer
autor oder in bezug auf eine moderatorin
ausgebeutet sind klassische beispiele wo
der bundesgerichtshof schuld und früher
die aussagen für menschenwürde
verletzend und unzulässig erachtet hat
hier hat das gericht entscheiden müssen
geben wir auskunft über die wagen über
den namen des täters und hatte es
abgelehnt weil sie sagen das sei keine
beleidigung keine schmierung ich kann es
nicht nachvollziehen
eine sehr klare einordnung von ihnen
jetzt versuchen wir trotzdem vielleicht
noch mal gemeinsam da können sie uns
helfen ja juristisch in die köpfe der
richter sozusagen zu schauen also was
die entscheidungsfindung nebenan geht
denn es ist ja eine abwägungssache und
ob etwas als beleidigung zu bestrafen
ist oder unter das gute meinungsfreiheit
befällt wo sind da die grenzen vor
einigen welche kriterien werden
grundsätzlich bei sowas angelegt die ab
also wenn es doch irgendwie eine
sachliche mir denn das tatsächliche
anknüpfen
also wenn es für eine meinungsäußerung
noch hinreichend anknüpfung staat sachen
geht dann darf man auch sehr scharf
formulieren aber die abwägung entfällt
wenn die menschenwürde der person
betroffen ist wie es hier der fall ist
aussagen wie drecks [ __ ] oder sie ist
das kind nicht genug griff und so weiter
worden das hat mit einer sachlichen
kritik nichts mehr zu tun eine seiner
abwägung nicht mehr möglich und wie
gesagt der sound der republik ist
ohnehin schon so verhärtet und
verwahrlost im netz dass hier der
rechtsstaat gefordert ist dem grenzen zu
setzen
wenn aber so ein urteil daher kommt
passiert genau das gegenteil wir werden
noch mehr verwirrung im netz verfahren
das heißt wer rechtsstaat muss hier
grenzen setzen die gerichte so müssen
ermutigt werden und den mut haben
solchen sachen budget zu begegnen
möglicherweise andere gerichte auch
anders geurteilt also könnte man
vielleicht auch die frage stellen ob es
dann kann das berliner landgericht ein
bisschen ja ich sag mal laxer dann
entscheiden wie es da ihre einschätzung
nein überhaupt nicht
bei dieser landgericht wie gesagt ich
kenne sogar die kammer sehr gut weil ich
da jede woche verhandle andere sachen
braucht meistens gegen boulevard medien
oder die bild zeitung ich kann das
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen was da
wirklich passiert ist die
urteilsbegründung ist derart falsch muss
ich sagen sie wird auch keinen bestand
haben da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher das
urteil darf auch keinen bestand haben
weil es ist wie gesagt ein verheerendes
signal für den rechtsstaat wäre und wie
würde des menschen
renate künast hat ja schon angekündigt
den beschluss des landgerichts dagegen
vorzugehen
ich kann dieses urteil von der nicht
stehenden instanz noch mal kassiert
werden selbstverständlich und also was
glauben sie dass es ihr ein auto wie es
da weiter dass ich also ich würde mich
wirklich wundern wenn dieses urteil
bestand hat ich habe schon viele
prozesse auch schmähkritik prozesse
geführt
er hat auch schon auf der anderen seite
gestanden also dass er ist in der
begründung so dünn und so falsch sei
überzeugt ja sonst nichts ihnen so
vorlesen kann es ja kann man es ja schon
länger nach fonds und das würde dann
bedeuten in der konsequenz dass facebook
die daten tatsächlich herausgeben wird
und dann könnte frau künast dagegen
vorgehen gegen die personen vor gibt es
ist ja auch gerade das phänomen im
internet ist ja man darf anonym hetzen
das heißt man muss noch nicht mal seinen
namen nennen um derartige beleidungen
raushauen zu können und wenn es dann
noch nicht mehr möglich ist diese leute
zu verfolgen weil diese aussage noch als
zulässig bewertet werden das ist
wirklich eigentlich dass das
das endet dann war das für eine
bankrotterklärung für die frage der
menschenwürde oder wie wollen wir
miteinander in der gesellschaft umgehen
und reden welche welche sprachqualität
wollen wir noch ertragen
ein sehr komplexes sehr spannendes thema
der medienanwalt christian schertz war
dass ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für
die einordnung bei uns vielen dank
[Applaus]